i grew up in my neighborhood we didn't
have a lot of diversity in my
neighborhood diversity is always
people's talking about it
and we didn't have it you know my
neighborhood was poor black poor white
that was our neighborhood you know
so i didn't feel any white privilege i
know some people had it man
you know i knew some [ __ ] with
sweaters
but i was two tank tops in the winter
okay
and i just didn't feel it you know i
wish i'd had some white privilege do
sign me up but i didn't have it man it
was just poor black kids poor white kids
man
and my poor black friends would always
like man look what you did to us
and i'm like dude do you think i would
do all that [ __ ] to y'all
and then move right next door bro
now we going to split this plum or not
dawg
we're in this together man
it was hectic sometimes fighting with
black kids is tough i don't know if you
ever fought a bunch of black dudes but
they win
they win dude
dude i got jumped one time after a
football game by five black dudes i
don't know if you ever fought five black
dudes at night
just imagine you're fighting five black
dudes right now close your eyes
now how many black dudes are you
fighting as many as your imagination can
hold
and white kids are horrible too man it
was just in poverty it's just that's
what's going on man
and if you're a black guy and you feel
like that's racially insensitive then
imagine you're fighting five white dudes
in a cloud
like damn this cloud is aggressive
and accurate
do you feel you you have white privilege
uh
i um i will i'm not allowed to answer
those questions
of being a old white guy with extra
money
you're great uh special that's on
netflix now everybody should watch it's
called
straight white male 60 yeah so you you
labeled yourself in there well i thought
i just
that's what i was but but the only
review i read of my special
and your kids can look it up but i think
i was referenced as
racist at least 10 times
even the bit i did about irish people
flying an airplane
yeah and they didn't reference the
edgiest joke i've ever done and i don't
even know why i did it
imagine to my snl fan so here's here's
here's the joke oh i'm a straight white
male and i know i'm probably you know
racist sex is xenophobic homophobic all
that you know
and you know and it's it i get it my
ancestors did some nasty stuff i mean
they raped pillar plundered took over
countries and slave people but you gotta
admit they were busy
you get the biggest laugh out of north
the value you look at her
and then you wonder how long they would
look for if she was missing
[Applause]
come on take a look take a look look at
this
i saw you look mad sweetie how long if
you was missing how long do you think
they were
how long did they do exactly she don't
even she went
you know the deal i ain't saying nothing
wrong white woman's life is valuable
what's his name jordan uh vandersloot
right we find out he was a serial killer
man he kills women that's what he do he
do it well
you know what i mean we know the girl
that he that he you know supposedly had
uh what's girl in aruba natalie holloway
right but the one he just killed a girl
in peru what's her name
um exactly
[Applause]
look up as you said now you said natalie
natalie
holloway that angel
y'all said that like family feud all
right name a white girl been missing for
five years the river
highway survey
name a peruvian girl that was killed
yesterday
what is that big head third world
peruvian bitch's name
it has to be yodis or something goofy
don't get mad at yourself i gave it to
you you saw how fast you said natalie
holloway
diana ross right here said nah she knew
her name
that white guy with natalie holloway
man you called yourself uh whoa
god bless you man that is high level
right then don't be ashamed of it
gorgeous
she mad as hell [ __ ] that white [ __ ]
you know come on
come on ain't nobody looking for you
i might look for you but the news ain't
you
you think fox is reporting you missing
let's be honest
nancy grace she leads story on nancy
grace
for the next six months
i look at her cause she's mad as hell
black we don't like that [ __ ] but it is
what it is let's be
i'm gonna be like that let's just let's
be honest
that little girl that went missing um
she was sailing
little girl was saying i forgot damn it
but she was she went sailing went
missing
in the indian ocean okay and
they spent good lord her mass broken she
was floating around
and she gave out her little signal her
beacon they look for they spent 500 000
like tax money to search for her now
that's my daughter i want that to happen
too but but
if you go sailing
let's be honest how long you think they
gonna spend five come on
remember hey remember football players
in miami went missing
they went sailing they looked for them
for eight
minutes maybe they just sent somebody at
the edge of the beach
i don't i don't see him
we have to call off the search because
it's too much sun
uh the sun the conditions are abnormally
difficult
if i go sailing i'm taking a white baby
on a key chain with me
if my boat go down they gonna find me
i'm gonna have it hook right to the side
of my belt
and i'm gonna dress the baby real white
too i'm gonna uh put sweatpants on it
and a pair of ugg boots and i'm gonna
take a picture look at this white baby
you don't come get me this white baby
going down with me
bothers white people that you're not
being used to told being told that you
can't do something
oh yeah yeah we just run around doing
whatever the [ __ ] we want to do
it's great ah jesus christ
that's that's one of the great
stereotypes is that we're all kennedy's
living on [ __ ] martha's vineyard
rather than [ __ ]
you know the majority of white people
aren't the majority of white people
sitting in cubicles
not living their dream drowning in a sea
of [ __ ] debt trying to get health
insurance isn't that the majority of
[ __ ] white people
evidently not evidently according to
this guy
white people have yachts
[Music]
sailing the world all 300 million of us
you know did you see it during that the
gulf war uh the gulf spill there
you know that was one of the biggest
problem all those white people all the
300 million white people with their
[ __ ] yachts just sailing around
oh it's so awesome to be white you can
just walk you can do it and say whatever
you want to do it's
[ __ ] incredible um
that's an argument i've gotten into uh
with uh
um i think every [ __ ]
yeah female comics black comics
every [ __ ] they just go yeah it's easy
for you
all you gotta do is show up man oh yeah
that's all it is
i don't even audition i just lay here
and they they call me up
and i'm like why why did you give me
that part then because you're white
here you go you don't have to work for
[ __ ]
uh you know that's that classy you know
that's that [ __ ] double standard
right there okay now we're opening a
whole nother can of worms let's talk
race for the next couple of weeks people
this ought to bring out a lot of
ugliness
um that's that classic [ __ ] like
that's one of those statements like you
if you flip that thing
what you just said there that
generalization that you made of white
people that basically what we just sit
around and did people just give us [ __ ]
and we can do whatever the [ __ ] we want
to do you're basically going to define
us by the illuminati
um
if you flip that around and somebody
white says that about another race of
people then they're
in like a mel gibson situation all right
now i'm open this up for discussion i'm
not opening this up for [ __ ] rednecks
to come on here
uh and be like yeah that's what the [ __ ]
i'm talking about i'm not saying it like
that
you know what i like that this podcast
is this difficult now you guys can
relate to me you know you're sitting
there in your goddamn cubicles on a
[ __ ] monday
unless you're white of course you're out
on your yacht you know chatting it up
with a kennedy
hey when's the stock market going to
crash again give me the heads up
don't tell the puerto ricans
that's what it's like that's exactly
what it's like
there's not white people working farms
slaves to corporations
ah not at all not at all all you do you
don't have to get up you don't have to
get up i spent nine years in bed
just because i was white and they just
[ __ ] hilarious i made more money then
than when i worked
that's how great it is to be white it's
so [ __ ]
easy and thank god for people who aren't
white who've never been white
to tell me what it's like to be white
it's [ __ ] awesome